[Musique]
alors que varsovie dit avoir empêché des
milliers de migrants de traverser quatre
mille personnes sont regroupées dans la
zone la biélorussie est accusé par
l'union européenne d'encourager
d'entrées légales d'étrangers en pologne
benetton créé la polémique et propose un
voile islamique unisexe un voile
islamique pour homme la cinquième vague
a commencé en europe au royaume uni en
allemagne plus de 30 mille nouveaux cas
supplémentaires sont enregistrées chaque
jour et d'autres pays en représailles
aux sanctions que bruxelles l'ue a
imposé pour violations des droits de
l'homme c'est grâce à vos efforts la
situation en france est plus favorable
l'augmentation de 40% en une semaine de
notre taux d'incidence est la remontée
des hospitalisations sont des signaux
d'alerté j'espère que l'on va pas encore
entendre ce soir des discours qui tombe
d'en haut
touchant la vie quotidienne des français
un appel à l'esprit de responsabilité
des six millions d'entre vous qui n'ont
encore reçu aucune dose de vaccin
vaccinez vous vacciner vous pour vous
protéger ce qu'on ne dit pas avant on ne
fera pas après donc tous ceux qui ne
s'engageront pas à faire un certain
nombre de suppressions de postes dans la
fonction publique ne les feront pas
après simplement éviter valérie de dire
trop de choses avant trop précisément de
ne pas les faire après comme on l'a dit
ce que j'allais faire avant que j'ai
réussi dans ma région à faire deux
milliards d'économies a jeté un peu la
cible non écoutez c'est peut-être la
pression vous avez eu tout cas je suis
très touché par l'attention tuent 19
d'éval intentions mais
attention
j'ai fait des propositions claires
parfois ils font semblant de ne pas les
comprendre on pas faire semblant de ne
pas comprendre qu'il y aurait une
saisine du parlement chaque année pour
faire exactement ce que tu dis puisque
j'avais d'ailleurs ni parlement avant
toi que le parlement devrait se
prononcer chaque année sur les quotas et
peut-être à l'unisson je revendique d'en
parler depuis des années parce que je
suis dans une raison
des attaques que xavier bertrand finit
par suivre lui aussi moi je veux pas
attendre je le dis à michel barnier je
veux pas attendre trois à cinq ans pour
régler le problème devenu un passage
incontournable
l'un des premiers ce matin et jean
castex
accueilli notamment par le petit fils du
général de gaulle 13h45 pour fournir
philippot 14h15 pour nicolas dupont
aignan 14h55 réservé par le président
dlr pour réunir sa famille politique au
lendemain du premier débat colombey les
deux églises c'était donc the place to
be je suis gaulliste du 18 juin je pense
que cet homme est un homme
général de gaulle évidemment a eu ce
courage immense je crois qu'il
réformerait la constitution mais l'on
ferait qu'on m'a notamment il ferait
voter une loi constitutionnelle pour
limiter les flux migratoires je vais lui
valérie pécresse en quelques cents
ouvriers pécresse est serré de faire du
général de gaulle je sais je suis
modeste quand je viens ici chaque année
je vais je pourrais vivre dans une
grotte je serais quand même si on est en
élection présidentielle ou pas parce que
la plupart 90% de ceux qui vont venir
aujourd'hui je les ai jamais vus avant
ils reviendront plus après ceux qui ont
signé des traités européens qui ont
détruit d'indépendance de la france
viennent se prosterner parade est ici ça
me fait un peu de peine alors voilà et
puis je remarque que ceux qui divisent
les français ne sont pas venus et c'est
tant mieux nous partageons rassemblement
national avec le général de gaulle la
vision que je viens de vous décrire sur
la vision d'une france encore une fois
indépendante souveraine forte comment il
réagirait le général de gaulle en voyant
ce défilé là je pense qu'ils les
remettraient à grand coup de pompe dans
le derrière à certains parce que il y en
a qui n'ont pas leur place et c'est pas
ça le gaullisme après balances ton port
le hashtag balances ton bar des fermes
sur le web le phénomène arrive de
belgique le principe est simple nommé un
établissement où une femme a été victime
d'agressions de harcèlement sexuel ou
encore de consommation involontaire de
ghb la fameuse drogue du viol voici la
première image de thomas pesquet de
retour sur terre à bord de la capsule
crew dragonne lui et son équipage font
savoir d'un geste de la main que tout
s'est bien passé